our next story sounds like it could come
from science fiction we're talking about
new technology that may someday
transform the lives of people who are
paralyzed a small clinical trial is now
underway on a brain implant that
captures your thoughts and then turns
those thoughts into language it's meant
for patients whose bodies are unable to
process messages from the brain because
of a stroke or als or multiple sclerosis
what's the word here ferocious sclerosis
he's trying to say eventually it could
also help people injured in car crashes
or on the battlefield
chief medical correspondent and birthday
boy today by the way dr john lepouk
shows us how it works
at his home in melbourne australia 62
year old philip o'keefe struggles to do
the simple things many of us take for
granted getting dressed
washing myself
cleaning my teeth
feeding myself
all those things
are severely restricted
als took away his ability to control his
hands and body when you heard that there
was a device that could use your
thoughts to operate a mouse what did you
think
i laughed
i thought
this is science fiction type stuff but
it's not the realm of science fiction
anymore in april of 2020 o'keefe became
one of the first patients to receive a
stentrode brain computer interface
implant this is the stentrode that's the
device that goes inside the blood vessel
dr tom oxley ceo of new york city-based
syncron leads the development of the
device we've figured out how to deliver
the sensors into the brain without open
brain surgery
that's the huge advance here
inserted through the jugular vein the
device is implanted in the area of the
brain that controls movement signals
captured by a receiver in the chest are
sent wirelessly to a device that decodes
thoughts into commands for a digital
device the clinical study that we're
running is purely for digital device
control for people whose hands no longer
control digital devices
o'keeffe demonstrated his computer
skills by writing me this note his
thoughts focused on a mouse clicking
letter by letter the technology has the
potential to help a range of patients
whose bodies are unable to receive
messages from the brain come online
thank you
i can sort my emails
i can
surf the web
i can do
most things
that you can do
using your hands
to regain that independence can you
imagine a time in the future when we can
beam how we are feeling to somebody else
yes i do think that brain computer
interfaces eventually go into that realm
but
that's a long way away clinical trials
are continuing and so far five people
have received the implant including one
in new york city this gave me a reason
to keep on living
but two years ago i would have gone
oh what's the point
but now
i'm involved in this
and it's just been
the most exciting
two years of my life and that to philip
o'keefe
is mind-boggling
for cbs mornings i'm dr john lepuc
wow that's a wowzer yeah that is a
wowzer i mean the the ability to get
into the brain without opening up the
skull they go through the jugular vein i
mean who would have thought that would
be even possible just right i could see
a little bit of a downside though as
cool as it is suppose you're having bad
thoughts say for instance klaus was
getting on my nerves and i'm thinking
klaus you're getting all my nerves and
next you know it's typed out yeah house
never gets on my nerves i'm just using
him because he's in my eye line and i
really like him or klaus is smiling at
you but you've got the microbe on him
and he's telling you what's going on yes
i know but bravo bravo i think that's
amazing stuff and happy birthday to you
john lapook happy birthday to you